uh
well welcome to
this week's science live chat
google hangout
uh this is dick kerr i'm
a
senior writer very senior writer at
science magazine
i
cover earth and planetary
matters
today i'm filling in a bit for our usual
exoplanet
writer you digit about in charging
has to be out of the country
but uh today we have
uh two guests
who
will be able to answer
all your questions about exoplanets i'm
sure
the first is sarah seeger
massachusetts institute of technology
she is a
astrophysicist and planetary scientist
an unusual combination i would say
uh
but that means
she follows
exoplanet discoveries
uh thinks about how to
characterize
exoplanets what they're like
and
try to imagine
what they will be like
uh our other guest is uh
steven dick he's
an historian
uh
not an astronomer
or astrophysicist
but his specialty has been in
space history and astrobiology in
particular
and he's coming up on uh tenure as the
nasa
library congress
holding nasa library congress chair in
astrobiology
uh welcome sarah and steve
thank you
steve
is
outside the washington dc and uh
sarah
is uh back up at mit
uh
to get started
um
i had a couple questions my own
um
or
perhaps we could
we can start with one that uh
has been sent in uh
along the same lines as i was thinking
uh this question comes from uh j
it's uh
as follows i i know spectroscopic
analysis of small exoplanetary
atmospheres is very difficult to perform
what's your most optimistic estimate on
when we can definitively analyze for o2
or o3
uh that's oxygen and ozone i think what
j is getting at is
we're finding
lots of exoplanets
and they're getting smaller and smaller
and closer to
uh the size of earth
but
when can
we pick up
signs
on those planets
that there might be life there
oxygen
uh is a product of life
uh ozone
would
be a protective layer in the upper
atmosphere of an exoplanet so sarah
how quickly can we expect
this sort of thing to uh
to come to pass
well if you're waiting for the real
earth and finding
a planet just like earth with those
signs as we see in earth's atmosphere we
have to wait a very long time
unfortunately
however i'll just back up and then i'll
return to the earth question if we're
happy with something bigger than earth
we call them super earths maybe um
a couple of times the size of earth a
little less than that it actually could
be much sooner we
are going to try to find big earths
transiting small stars
and look at them with the james webb
space telescope so in the very very best
scenario if we're really lucky and find
the right objects to follow up we could
be looking at atmospheres of some kind
of terrestrial planets in about a decade
from now
that's uh
james webb goes up in
2018
exactly 2018 so let me think
yeah could be under a decade we have a
related mission going up called tess the
transiting extrasolar planet survey
satellite which will be led by mit
and tessa's goal is to find those rocky
super earths orbiting small stars
ones that the james webb can follow up
but i don't want to make it sound super
easy i mean
a lot of things have to align
uh for that kind of observation to
happen the sort of default that we were
thinking of all along
was to launch a very sophisticated space
telescope
under the umbrella term of terrestrial
planet finder and those telescopes would
be able to see the earth
if it's around one of the hundred
nearest stars
how was the
terrestrial planet finder coming along
they
have some technical challenges that
yeah uh were difficult proven difficult
to me
well terrestrial planet finder was a
term for a space-based telescope that
would block out the light of the parent
star because earth itself is not so
faint if we think about how faint would
an earth be about 30 light years away
it's not fainter than the faintest
galaxies we've ever observed with hubble
the problem is that it is right next to
a really bright star and you have to
block out the light of the star
on something like the order of 1 in 10
billion and visible wavelengths to see
the planet but trust the planet finder
which was funded at 50 million dollars a
year for several years actually was
stop funding it's kind of shelved we
can't use the term shelved
so it's not really going forward in an
official way however there's a lot of
activity still going on including
recently nasa just put together two
teams to study the possibility of doing
what they call a reduced scale tpf a
smaller mission that could still go up
there and directly image exoplanets
all right
steve
you've long followed the
uh
efforts to
uh
contact extraterrestrial life um
to
find
other planets around other stars
i'm just curious
um
what
what's driving this
this effort i mean see we're trying
harder and harder to
move ourselves farther and farther away
from the center of the universe
um
what what's the motivation why why is
nasa and other agencies uh putting that
kind of money into it
well i think there are a number of
drivers the first uh just a very general
one of exploration and discovery the
idea that we want to know what's out
there whether it's you know planets or
stars you know the whole
history of astronomy is driven by
curiosity
and the idea of there being life out
there is one of the most exciting things
because i think you know we being alive
identify with life so
it's certainly one of the greatest
scientific questions
and uh we've not been able to address it
very effectively
until the last 50 years or so
so um
you know we haven't been able to the as
sarah said the observations are so
difficult that we haven't been able to
detect anything until
uh well the the early 1990s when the
first pulsar planets were detected there
were some claims prior to that but not
proven uh and then in 1995 is when
things really broke open with the uh
with the uh first discovery of a planet
51 peg around uh around a sun like star
so uh the the drivers are exploration
discovery uh one of the greatest
scientific questions and it's also will
be a great philosophical question as you
said uh if we find life out there it's
going to affect uh our place in the
universe and i think that's a question
that everybody's interested in whether
it's microbial life or
or intelligent life we can talk about
what the different impacts might be but
i think there will be an impact in both
cases well um yeah be curious to get
your opinion on that one because a lot
of things took a very long time for
impact like think of the copernican
theory it took really till halley's
comment came back
twice hundreds of years before it was
really
accepted as to what it meant
so what are you talking about this would
mean i mean when the day comes what the
questioner didn't ask was when we see
signs of life or see oxygen in ozone
will we be 100 sure
and we won't be actually we won't be
able to be 100 sure with our first
generation telescopes the data will be
poor we won't necessarily be able to get
it in context of the rest of the
potential false positives so how many
countries do you think it will take for
people
well it depends on the scenario i think
it's very much scenario dependent if you
find a habitable planet of course that's
not the same thing as finding an
inhabited planet
and if you find a planet with microbes
on
somehow
then that's totally different from
getting a signal from extraterrestrials
so
uh i think one of the interesting
approaches would be
analogs in in earth history and you have
to be very careful with analogs of
course you can't predict anything
as you say the copernican theory took a
long time to
to even be accepted much less have much
of an impact
so
i think it will have an impact
depending on the scenario
even with microbes because you remember
back in 1996 when the announcement was
made about the alh 8401 the the mars
rock
well that was just the claim of fossil
life and you remember in the newspapers
all the excitement throughout the media
what are the implications of this what
might the theological implications be
well the theological implications of
fossils i think would not be so great
but it's it's the fact that there's
you know there has been
life out there that possibility now we
now know that that or the consensus now
on the mars rock is that that was not uh
fossilized life found in there but uh
you know if you find a
microbial life somewhere i think the
same questions will be asked
because if you have microbial life then
it's more likely that you will somehow
uh evolve intelligent life and of course
are huge gaps in our understanding not
only about the origins of life but about
the
about the uh evolution of life
especially to intelligence so i think
it's going to depend entirely on what
the scenario uh is
uh and if it's intelligent life of
course it will depend on whether we get
a message and whether we decipher the
message and what the message says and
that sort of thing so there's a whole
range of possibilities here when you
talk about the societal implications and
but it's quite possible as you say that
it will
uh take quite a long time to have an
impact and there are lots of
of uh because i think it's going to be a
kind of a world view just uh you know
the the idea there being
extraterrestrial life out there is a
kind of a world view
just like the copernican world view and
the darwinian world view and you see
what impact those had eventually so it
may take some time but i think it will
definitely have an impact
thanks steve
uh
everybody out there do remember that
if you want to ask a question just
scroll down
uh
pass those pretty pictures of related
articles and
you'll find the
message box
where you can leave your question
i was wondering um
sarah we we talk very uh globally
sometimes about
finding
uh mother earth
or the next
earth-like planet
um
and and that gives a
a picture in your mind of
you know blue seas white clouds
lots of land
just
how
bizarre might be
uh another earth
something
in its habitable zone
with the right conditions for life
but maybe not so familiar to us
well that's a really great question and
we should start out by remembering or
thinking about the huge number of
exoplanets the huge diversity in the
exoplanets that have been found you know
we can't really find a true earth yet we
can find planets that are kind of earth
size a little bigger than earth size
and that's going on in a big way with
the kepler space telescope right now but
what we are seeing is that there are
exoplanets of all sizes all masses and
all orbits out there it's incredible
it's like rolling the dice a dice that
has like you know a thousand different
sides and getting a planet that is
different almost every time
it's really remarkable of what's out
there and actually as an aside one of
the my favorite discoveries in the last
decade with it's with the kepler space
telescope and kepler has found that the
most common type of planet out there so
far that we can tell it's not jupiter's
it's not jupiter-sized planets it's
small planets around two earth radii
twice the size of earth
which we have no solar system
counterpart for
so in our own solar system we have earth
that's earth size by definition we have
neptune and uranus which are about four
times the size of earth but we don't
have these two earth-sized objects we
don't even really know how they have
formed
so it's a crazy
it's a crazy galaxy of planetary systems
out there
and so when we try to think about which
types of planets would be habitable
it really would be i mean we have to be
more broad and that's what my article
was about last week in science which
kind of led us to this conversation
today and it was saying well what if we
just don't worry so much of being about
so fixated on earth
and go back to the basic requirements of
life what kinds of planets could be
habitable
and in my article i was just reviewing
the literature so it's really kind of i
can't call it a community census
consensus because people didn't really
realize it was a consensus yet
but it's if you just ask what is
required for life and one of the main
requirements is a liquid environment and
we've always choose liquid water because
all life on earth needs liquid water and
it's about an abundant planetary
material around planets that are
accessible in the future it leads to
observations and then it turns out
there's a lot of different types of
planets that could have liquid water at
the surface
a couple of the ones that i mentioned
that
um one of them includes
okay well i think we need to back up a
bit here but then you say well planet
needs liquid water but what controls
let's just wait for that
okay well for liquid water you know what
controls our atmosphere surface
temperature well everybody does really
know it's the greenhouse effect the
greenhouse gases in our atmosphere so
essentially we have to think about other
types of planets and which kind of
greenhouse gases might they have and
what kind of effect may those greenhouse
gases have
and we find that some planets very
different from earth have very different
groups
and
that's actually leads us to consider
very diverse worlds that could be
habitable i'll mention just two of them
briefly
one of them is the so-called world with
the hydrogen atmosphere our own earth
doesn't have hydrogen because it's light
gas and it escapes to space
the kind of analogy is like a child
holding a helium balloon if you let go
of the balloon it just floats away but
there are planets that will be massive
enough or cold enough so that won't
happen and they'll be able to retain
hydrogen and helium and hydrogen it
turns out is a very powerful greenhouse
gas
it's bad news if i mean if we had if our
planet was able to retain hydrogen it
would actually be way too hot here on
our surface for liquid water
but the good news from the flip side of
that is that for planets further from
the star
twice as far or 10 times as far even as
earth more slightly more massive earths
they could retain hydrogen and have a
surface that is compatible with liquid
water so we could have planets quite far
from the star that are habitable
um one other type of planet i'll mention
is a very dry planet on our own planet
water vapor is our biggest greenhouse
gas and if we can imagine a planet with
a lot less water vapor like fewer oceans
smaller amount of oceans smaller water
vapor
that planet wouldn't overheat and it
could actually be located much closer to
its star than earth is to the sun
and still have surface liquid water so
it's really all about the greenhouse
gases and we don't actually have a great
idea a priori in advance
of what atmospheres look like on other
planets so we're just speculating that
they will be diverse
just as diverse as the range of types of
planets that are out there
sarah has a can if i could ask a
question has there been any attempt to
uh to classify from a physical point of
view these planets i mean in our solar
system we have terrestroplanets gas
giant planets and some people say ice
giant planets do all the
uh do all of the planets that have been
discovered so far fall in one of those
categories or is there a new
class about i pray that new classes are
emerging although they're not yet agreed
upon
figure out the concept of ice giants
because these small planets i'm talking
about are found close to the star we
can't really find planets so far away is
to be made of ice yet right so divide it
up we do divide it up based on physics
we have and i'll use the kepler
terminology because kepler has found so
many objects it goes by planet size and
kepler say anything smaller than about
one and a quarter times the size of
earth we'll call that earth earth earth
size
anything between about um one and a
quarter and two or three adi i can't
remember if they're choosing one point
seven five or two or three di we'll call
super earth and a super earth is
something we want to call that's
dominated by rock it's
predominantly rocky made of solid
material with just thin atmosphere and
we know that from models
that's
that's a reasonable cutoff for the
abundant planetary materials anything
between
um about two to six earth radii
they're um
um
i'm trying to think of what they call
but we could refer to it as a mini
neptune and these would be planets that
would have about 10 10 to 20 percent of
their mass would be in hydrogen but half
of their volume
so these are planets that are not fully
dominated by
hydrogen helium
but they're kind of in between kind of
like uranus and neptune and then
anything above six
we're calling those giant planets
meaning that they're dominated by
hydrogen and helium
so i don't really hear anything
different from
the physical classes that we have i mean
a super earth a super earth is still a
terrestrial planet rocky planet right
right that's correct but there's this
finer division because we're not sure if
those super earths will behave like
earth when we think about the interior
conditions the pressure is too high
inside okay worry that things like plate
tectonics will be different so yes
you're right it's kind of the same i was
thinking out loud here except for
awesome terrestrial planets is now
divided in two right
so sarah
um just looking at um
upcoming talk
out at the seti institute uh
gentlemen terence deacon is uh
seems to be
raising uh
questions about the advisability of
uh confining ourselves to
some of the
constraints for the origin of life that
you uh
mentioned
uh
such as
liquid water
uh
seems to have some ideas about
broadening
the conditions that uh
lead life is is that a um
uh of interest
considering liquids other than water for
example
um
solid-state
uh processes um
broadening things even more
well of course in science fiction they
always talk about silicon life and
crystalline life and all kinds of things
like that but the normal answer to that
is that we have enough problem trying to
find carbon-based life even though i
think you have to uh
you know you have to realize
our
definition of
limits of life has greatly expanded
because of the discovery of hydrothermal
events and extremophile life uh and life
you know inside uh deep down on the
earth and
and all that sort of thing so um
you know there are different
you can
you can talk about non-carbon life but
uh there's plenty to talk about within
within carbon life uh but i do think you
have to consider
uh the extremophiles have made it more
likely that there could be uh life out
there because it seems to thrive under
conditions of you know acidity and
temperature and all kinds of things
pressures that that uh you know 30 years
ago we wouldn't have dreamed of
yeah well let me that's a really great
question let me think about that for a
second i'll just think and um
basically um
there was this really interesting report
by the national academy of sciences and
they revisited this question about what
are the requirements for life and they
actually broadened it a bit they wanted
to be less we call it pterocentric less
focused on earth
and they came up with well you don't
necessarily need liquid water but they
agreed that some kind of liquid is
necessary for chemical reactions to
occur
and to be able to
you know broadly
mix up and build more complicated
molecules
so in that sense we do like the idea of
a liquid it doesn't have to be water
but in a case with planetary materials
water is the most abundant planetary
material we can go further and further
away from a sun a star
like titan for example one of saturn's
moons has liquid not liquid water but
liquid ethane and methane lakes so
that's certainly a place that we could
consider for more exotic life for the
search for exoplanets it
it is going to sound very pterocentric
but it's very hard for us to see planets
that far from the star they're faint
thermally paint and reflected light etc
now i'll return to this question about
solid state you know i haven't
i'm seeing that investigated in a lot of
detail so i can't say whether i think
it's possible or not but i do want to
reassure you one thing
and that is that what we're really
looking for in exoplanets we're looking
at the atmospheres for biosignature
gases gases that have accumulated that
are produced by life and are able to
accumulate in the atmosphere and be
detected remotely
so
um
you know it's possible that in the
future we can find some crazy atmosphere
where some gas is orders of magnitude
out of equilibrium and we may never
really know what's at the surface maybe
there's just a tiniest bit of water
vapor that's not really relevant for
that life so we're not actually going to
know if it's silicon based or carbon
based or
where that life is really being made or
living we're actually looking not for
what life is but what life does life
metabolizes and produces gases that's
the theory the concept we're adopting
and the paradigm we can search in so
certainly i guess there's still some
room for a really different kind of life
as long as we can get atmosphere
measurements of enough exoplanets out
there and then try to piece together
what's happening
right uh i understand we've been having
some technical difficulties on our end
uh
difficulties uh getting
questions to uh registered
uh
so
might be time to
go back down to the uh comment bar and
uh put your question in
in the meantime
um
sarah was wondering if
if you could give us a
more of an idea of
how things might be
progressing in the immediate future in
the exoplanet department
um
finding these super earths
supersized earths
uh a couple times bigger than earth or a
little smaller
uh
when
i guess kepler when is kepler going to
when it might
uh
give us
actual earth-sized planets
well that's a great
already done
um kepler actually has already given us
earth-sized planets it has given us even
smaller planets down basically smaller
than mercury so kepler is delivering on
tiny planets
however in the habitable zones of stars
the so-called traditional habitable zone
like earth's habitable zone kepler is
fine planets slightly bigger than earth
so far
so it certainly started to deliver in
terms of what we call earth's earth size
or super earth size in the habitable
zones
we're waiting for kepler to accumulate
more statistics so that kepler can
answer the question
how common are earth-sized planets in
habitable zones of sun-like stars
so if things keep
progressing
kepler keeps working
um
a matter of time
correct
uh
about uh kepler um
it's been working pretty well i
understand
uh and it's now in his extended mission
uh
how much longer
does it have
programmatically to run
well
kepler is in the extended mission it
will go up for senior review it's a nasa
process to decide which missions get to
live even longer next spring
so programmatically we would all be
hopeful and confident that it would
get extended mission and to keep going
because it builds on time the data
accumulates and the more time you have
the better actually for kepler
so that would be great news um
you know kepler wasn't designed to last
forever so there's always the
possibility that something could go
wrong and its lifetime is shortened
naturally
yeah i'd just like to say that
kepler is an example of uh the
difference that one person can make
you have a very nice article in science
about bill baruchy and i remember
hearing bill baruchi back in the 1980s
talking about this
and he persisted and persisted despite
the ups and the downs and the budget
cuts and
and the rejections and
you see what what it's ended up with i
mean almost all space missions have
near-death experiences but uh once they
get up there they really uh
they really
perform and this is certainly an example
of that
yeah there's a real nice um
profile that my colleague about a charge
he did of uh bill baruchy
uh quite the
saga
of
rookie
proposing this
kepler technique of
watching planets pass in front of their
stars
and
recording the dimming of the stars
apparently it was not
uh
immediately well received
and he had the campaign for
for many years to
to sell the idea and get it funded and
get the spacecraft
out there
uh
a little concern we may still be having
some technical problems
uh might be time to reload and uh
try that comment bar again
so
how many
planets
of any size do we have in the
their habitable zone at this point sarah
well there's a subtlety there also if
you wanted to ask strictly how many
planets a handful i would say
if you want to ask how many planet
candidates that's we're not sure they're
planets yet but they're objects that
kepler has found that our planetary size
we just aren't sure if they're false
positives or if they're real planets
then it's more like a few dozen probably
what you've seen so far you expect many
many more right you definitely accept
many more yeah
yeah this is part of the kepler
process kepler detects these
transient dimmings of the star
and
they have kepler people have ways of
of uh
narrowing down the candidates
and
becoming rather confident
but then
they send them out for confirmation by a
second technique
and
that's pretty time consuming so we're
we wait uh
many months for the next cup for uh load
of
confirmed planets um
what the total exoplanet count is over
800 but the kepler confirmed
planets are
help me out 0 100 something um the
confirmed plans i think there's close to
100.
about 200.
2700 candidates though
yeah
well that'll be uh
what are these
these uh
announcements release of
new exoplanet from kepler come every six
months or so
uh
you just have to be patient yeah i've
been uh uh sarah i'd be interested to
know how
um confident you are that the
habitable planets will turn out to be
inhabited planets because i've you know
i followed this history uh you know uh
50 years ago a lot of people were saying
that
there were you know there's only
evidence for one
solar system and that's our own you know
and then when uh you know when the uh
first planets were discovered in the
1990s they said well those are gas
giants they're nothing like ours so they
wouldn't have life on and then we found
the super earth and they said well those
are super earth they're not like the
earth and then we found earth-sized ones
and people are saying well they're or
size that doesn't mean they're
earth-like so what do you think the
chances are uh that they're going to be
actually inhabited
i know that's a philosophical question
you know the only thing i can say is i
wouldn't be doing my job and waking up
early every morning if i didn't believe
there were a lot large number of
probable and inhabited worlds out there
okay
so i mean we've seen that like every
star has planets and many of them appear
to have small planets as far as we can
tell hopefully there's
hopefully all of them have small planets
it's really just a matter of chance
right however the thing with the kepler
or planets most people don't realize is
that in any time in the near future
we're not going to be able to probe
those particular planets for signs of
life on them
those kepler field of views
see stars that are just too far away
yeah the kepler stars are what on the
order of 1500 light years away something
like that right yeah or more even yeah
yeah
well it looks like uh
the the gates have opened and uh people
are getting through
uh so we've got a few questions on this
end
um
well here's one from eric goldstein
uh there are 23
known star systems within
12 light years of earth
i'll take care of its uh word for that
uh we'll test that's the
uh this upcoming
mission that sarah mentioned
will test
look at all of them
um
wait what do you say 23 within how many
light years
well uh 12 light years of earth
oh
if they're in the habitable zone around
oh planet okay once in a while test look
at it
the answer is almost certainly yes
because
tess will be looking at 500 000 stars
all down to what we call about
um
you know 15th or 16th
so
yes almost certainly those will be on
the test list
all right
thank you the only reason why i was
hesitating is because tess has limits in
what kind of planets it can actually
observe or detect
and they may not be fully consistent
with the planetary planets in those
planetary systems so if you have a small
planet
orbiting sun like star
tests will not be able to see that small
planet around that big of a star so
those stars will all be on the list but
whether tess can see each planet if they
were transiting may not happen
and when did you say tess was going up
tess is going to launch in 2017.
hopefully june of 2017. okay seems like
a long time away but actually that's
really short for the amount of time
there is to
build and integrate and test and launch
right
is it is it even designed yet sir oh
absolutely we went through what we call
what's called a phase a competition
and to
pass that competition at nasa it's a
funded phase
lasts about nine months you have to have
basically a complete design
right i mean even prototype cameras were
built two different ones and they went
through two different tests one was a
shake test where it's shaken and see if
it survives
that the optical elements are still
lined up properly inside the lens the
other test was a thermal cycling test
where you heat it and cool it down and
make sure that it still performs
the way you want it to
all right well we'll uh
look forward to uh 2017.
you may not all be in this business
at that time but
uh
another question from
fungus123
uh
gentlemen with uh dark glasses
uh are there useful insights from your
work that might inform our efforts to
colonize mars
uh sound like one for you
um let sarah think
there's no really direct connection
between the search for exoplanets and
the study for signs of life on them and
mars itself only because
in colonizing mars only because we're
doing everything remotely we know that
we want to be able to go to these other
exoplanets far away but that's not
really feasible in the short term so we
think more in terms of remote sensing
launching a large space telescope to
look at the exoplanets
and for mars going there and
terraforming it's really a completely
different story
but it does hear one thing and that is
you know the colonization of space
opening up space how to build big
complicated things in space or far away
in that sense it's related but it
doesn't really inform it directly
okay
we're back
i mean it's a great topic it's still one
of my favorite topics but we don't it's
not directly related
all right
uh we seem to be having
yet more technical difficulties
all new to me being a
hangout newbie
uh let's see
anybody else's um
yep
we're still coming through
uh
i guess this is the inevitable question
uh
from mike c
sarah do you
ever think about what this alien life
might look like
funnily enough i have thought of it and
you know why it's partly motivated by
morgan freeman one time i was invited to
be on his show
it's called through the wormhole and he
was doing an episode on exoplanets in
life it's kind of fun actually and what
i did with one of my colleagues my
colleagues william baines was they
wanted us to think what life would be
like and it's quite fascinating actually
there are other like evolutionary
biologists who have thought of these
things because the exoplanets are so
different from earth we could imagine a
really awesome type of planet one of
those lo we call them the low density
mini neptunes where maybe they have
water at the surface but their
atmospheres are so massive that the air
pressure at the surface is a similar
density to water imagine that if the air
gets so heavy and thick because the
atmosphere is so massive that the ocean
water and the air above it are about the
same density when you think of something
like that you could imagine life that is
like
uh i don't know what you would call but
think of amphibious life that can live
on the water and land but it would be
life that can live in the water and air
because there's a smooth transition so
you can imagine flying fish
and then you can go and think through it
systematically and think well what would
they look like how would their wings
look if it's easier or harder to get
lift in the air and things like that and
then you can think further on such a
planet these are my favorite type of
planets to you know dream about but
is it so dark at the surface because the
atmosphere is so heavy maybe you can
imagine some type of plants or flying
birds that have photosynthesis ability
in their wings because they have to go
high up
to get to the sun so those are the real
things that we think about about what
would really animal like be like on
these other worlds that have very
different pressures and conditions than
earth does
yeah i think carl sagan once postulated
the possibility of balloon-like
jellyfish in the higher atmosphere of
jupiter of our gas giants in general
yeah exactly exactly what i was
recalling see
science are tricky because one thing
that happens on gas giants is the air
currents
circulate and we brought quite deep down
where it's so hot right
for the complex molecules for life to
survive so we actually have a whole new
range of things to think about now with
these other planets we with these other
planets that will have some kind of
surface won't be too hot
but certainly that concept could work on
a super earth as well
all right
king kong asks
what will be the next step after the
telescopic confirmation of a habitable
planet
i
i'm taking that to mean
that
we found
a
more or less earth size or maybe super
earth
in that zone
at the crucial distances from its star
where
conditions
would allow
liquid water at the surface well that
typically that's the next step i mean we
kind of have planets like that already
we're not sure if they have surface
water but there are planets that are
kind of earth's size a little bigger a
little more massive
in the so-called habitable zone so we're
there now and so what do you want to do
next what we want to do next is we want
to find planets like that that we can
look at their atmospheres and see if
indeed they have water we can't see
water on the surface but we could see
water vapor in the atmosphere we'd like
to do that next
and that's basically our next step
um if you wanted to what was the
question specifically though did he ask
about a habitable planet or
in the habitable zone because those are
very different i think the great
question is what would we do next if we
found
or biosignature gases or gases that
don't belong right that would be really
great um
i mean i know what some people want to
do they want to figure out a way to go
there
i think that's a really serious
consideration i mean there's two answers
to it one is people are going to want to
figure out how to go there whether they
send a robotic probe or figure out a way
to go on their own that will be a huge
motivation for the whole world of
interplanet interstellar travel i think
on the other hand you know what
astronomers do though it's kind of i
won't say it's lame because i'm excited
about it but they just want to build a
better telescope
and then when we see signs of life it's
not going to be
a slam dunk okay it's going to be like
yes it's kind of we're confident maybe
at the 90 level 95 level but if we want
to be really sure
we will want to send up a bigger
telescope with a better spectrograph
higher resolution to see more details
about the atmosphere and that planet
itself
i was just going to say the problem is
if you have a whether it's robotic or a
human starship at distances of 1500
light years even if you go the speed of
light it's going to take you 1500 years
to get there
no those are way too far away we're
talking about the very nearest stars
like alpha centauri okay all of our
favorite stars we need to
well i skipped a step in between perhaps
we're talking about the habitable worlds
like kepler but we want to find the
habitable worlds that are much closer to
earth within
you know 3 5 10 twenty light years at
most that's what we're trying to find
all of those right now yeah it's still a
one year a one-way 20-year trip though
at the speed of light i'm just reading
and i'm reading the tea leaves here
about right
you know the sort of pulse on the people
the young people the people in the world
right what's going on i think it'll be a
huge motivator
steve aren't uh
aren't steady
researchers already targeting
uh
exoplanetary systems uh with their
searches
sure they they pretty much you know
before these exoplanets were found they
pretty much were flying blind they were
looking you know at solar type stars uh
and that sort of thing but now that they
have actual
planets and planetary systems that they
can look at they you know they can uh
they can do some of those targets but as
sarah said most of those are you know
the vast majority of the planets found
so far hot jupiter is very close to the
planet which wouldn't be
inhabited but it may indicate that there
are other planets in those systems
further out that haven't been seen so
i don't know um how many of those
they're targeting but i'm sure they're
targeting some yes
all right
well uh maybe to to wrap up here i've
got one um
well uh
king kong says
he or she
once you go there even it's too far
but uh ryan schmidt
asks
would you be disappointed if the first
life you discovered was microscopic or
bacterial
as compared to something such as a 200
foot dragon type alien so to speak
i'll go first then perhaps you can all
share your opinions
no i wouldn't be disappointed we have to
start somewhere and in fact we're
actually thinking that we're going to
find microscopic life first however let
me just add that when we see signs of
life from afar we won't know what is
causing that life like here on earth
we're breathing out carbon dioxide
that's not a great bio signature gas
because we already have a lot of carbon
dioxide in earth's atmosphere but it
could be that some kind of complex life
breathes out a type of gas that shows up
as a biosignature gas that we see
remotely and we won't know if it's
really caused by intelligent life or by
microbes
so i won't not only why not be
disappointed but i don't even think in
my lifetime i'm gonna know
what type of life created the sign that
i hope to find
yeah i wouldn't be disappointed either
although it would be more interesting if
you could found complex life and of
course that's what seti is all about if
you can actually get a signal you know
then you know that there's life there if
it's trying to communicate
so
seti in a way leapfrogs all these other
arguments by having direct contact
and uh that kind of scenario you know
when you talk about the impact of that
depends totally on whether you're able
to communicate and uh and what they're
saying so um that's why you know seti is
a has always been a extreme long shot
but
the payoff if you
if you find something could be great
whether for good or for ill depending on
on what they're like
well then i seem to recall
seth
chosdek
of the seti institute out in
mountain view california
telling me that
if
computer advances continue as they have
in the past
and we continue to make the effort uh
he would expect
uh first contact by
2025
uh if there's ever going to be any
contact so
that's very hard to predict but i
thought you were going to say another
thing that seth has said which i've
written about which is that if you take
the vast amounts of time that
intelligent life could have been around
that
life might not even be biological
anymore it could be post biological it
could be artificial
uh intelligence
because um you know
they may
have been able to develop
artificial intelligence and left the
biological part behind
that seems like total speculation but
there are reasons
to to believe that would be true over
long time periods
well we seem to have
moved beyond uh
the every day of exoplanets and
gotten a little uh far afield but uh
that's what the the search is all about
i guess
but why don't we wrap it up here uh
thanks so much sarah sieger
and uh steve dick
much enjoyed it much appreciate your
efforts and
we'll all be watching for
the next kepler development and looking
forward to
uh tests launch in 2017.
thanks a lot thanks very much thank you
bye bye